Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wiener
Neustadt, ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner, der
Leiter der Forschungsentwicklungsabteilung
der Theresianischen Militärakademie und derzeit
der Kommandant der Garde in Wien.
Heute am Tag 465 des Krieges in der Ukraine
wollen wir uns ansehen das Ergebnis der Einsatzführung
der russischen Streitkräfte der letzten Monate
und die erwarteten Maßnahmen der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte - Stichwort Offensive in den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten.
An erster Stelle ist da wichtig zu sagen
dass wir uns bedanken für die vielen Rückmeldungen
und auch Zuschriften zu unseren Videos. Es
ist eindeutig, völlig klar wer völkerrechtlich
der Angreifer ist und wer der Verteidiger.
Trotzdem versuchen wir so objektiv und neutral
wie möglich die Situation darzustellen, um
möglichst ein exaktes Lagebild von der
Front zu haben.
Es hilft an dieser Stelle überhaupt nichts,
die Russen zu unterschätzen und die Ukraine
zu überschätzen. Aus meiner Sicht schadet
es der Ukraine sogar noch mehr, wenn wir sie
permanent überschätzen und nicht realisieren,
wie die Lage tatsächlich ist. Und die Lage
ist sehr sehr ernst.
Damit beginnen wir.
Fassen wir kurz zusammen, was wir am Tag 465
feststellen können.
Wir können feststellen, dass die Ukraine
in den letzten Monaten und vor allem im letzten
Jahr es geschafft hat, den Raum Kiew, den
Raum
Charkiw und Cherson zurückzuerobern. Die
Frage
ist nun natürlich wie geht es weiter und
gelingt es der Ukraine die besetzten Gebiete,
die Russland noch hält, zurückzuerobern - und
hier natürlich die Frage, ob mit den bereitgestellten
Kräften - vor allem auch mit dem westlichen
Militärgerät - es gelingen kann, in die
Offensive zu gehen.
Sehen wir uns ganz kurz an das Ergebnis der
sogenannten russischen Winteroffensive, die
in den letzten Monaten stattgefunden hat.
Offensichtlich war es der Versuch der Russen,
weiter mit Schwergewicht im Donbass Richtung
Westen anzugreifen und auch die
beiden Oblaste Luhansk und Donezk zur Gänze
in Besitz
zu nehmen.
Man konnte sehr gut erkennen, dass die Russen
mehrere Schwergewichtsräume ausgewählt haben.
Einerseits im Süden bei Wuhledar, dann bei
Awdijiwka bei Bachmut, wo sich die Kämpfe
im Besonderen zugespitzt haben und in weiterer
Folge von Siwersk. Offensichtlich war es
auch die Absicht der Russen, die Ukraine zu
zwingen, ihre bereitgestellten Reserven - auch
jene Kräfte, die aus dem Westen angeliefert
worden sind - bereits zum Einsatz zu zwingen
und zwar in die Reichweite ihrer stärksten
Waffe und das ist nach wie vor die russische
Artillerie und auch die Raketenwerfer.
Zugespitzt hat sich die Situation besonders
im Raum Bachmut.
Sehen wir uns aber zuerst kurz den südlichen
Sektor an und zwar den Bereich von Wuhledar.
Hier war es so, dass Russland versucht hat,
signifikanten Raumgewinn durch einen Angriff
in einer Zangenbewegung zu erzielen.
Man hat versucht, einerseits aus dem Süden
und einmal aus dem Norden vorzustoßen.
Das Ergebnis war, dass in beiden Angriffen, die
durchgeführt worden sind, einmal Ende Jänner
und einmal Anfang Februar - einmal von Osten
kommend Richtung Wuhledar und einmal vom Westen
kommend Richtung Wuhledar - es den Russen nicht
gelungen ist, die ukrainischen Verteidigungsstellungen
zu durchbrechen, sondern im Gegenteil sehr
schwere Verluste erlitten haben.
Hier an dieser Stelle zeigen wir Ihnen ein
kurzes Video von diesen Kämpfen und den Versuch
des Vorstoßes der russischen Kräfte.
Das Ergebnis war, dass die Russen
mehrmals abgewehrt worden sind und schwerste
Verluste beigebracht bekommen haben.
Man konnte hier sehr gut erkennen, dass wenn
der Angreifer versucht, in die Offensive zu
gehen und der Verteidiger sich gut einrichtet,
eine gute Taktik anwendet und auch das Gelände
entsprechend nützt, durch den Einsatz von
Panzer bei Waffen und auch Minen, er dem Angreifer
schwere Verluste beibringen kann.
Die russische Seite hat aber auch erkannt,
dass mit zugeführten Reservisten es kaum
möglich ist, operative Räume zu gewinnen
aufgrund der Verfügbarkeit der Kräfte, die
in der Qualität nicht zu vergleichen sind
mit denen, die am Anfang des Krieges zur Verfügung
gestanden sind.
Das Ergebnis waren hohe Verluste, so wie wir
sie gesehen haben.
Im Zentralraum hat sich die Situation etwas
anders dargestellt.
Hier hat Russland versucht, Bachmut von
mehreren Seiten zu umfassen.
Einmal mit einem Angriff im Süden
und einmal im Norden.
Nach mehreren Wochen schwerer Kämpfe ist
es dann im März gelungen, tatsächlich bei
Soledar einen Durchbruch zu erzielen.
Ein Durchbruch analog zum Durchbruch bei Popasna
im letzten Jahr, wo auch der Durchbruch bei
Popasna dann schließlich zur Schlacht
von Lyssytschansk und Sjewerodonezk geführt
hat.
Und so war es auch hier so, dass dieser Durchbruch
bei Soledar dazu geführt hat, dass die Russen
es geschafft haben, mehr oder weniger Bachmut
im Norden und im Süden fast zur Gänze einzukesseln.
Die Russen haben dann umgruppiert.
Warum?
Weil sie nicht weiter vorstoßen wollten Richtung
Westen aufgrund der Bereitstellung von ukrainischen
Reserven, haben Fallschirmjägerkräfte im
Norden und im Süden platziert, haben die
Teile
von Wagner zusammengeführt und hier
versucht, zentral Richtung Westen angreifend
Häuserblock für Häuserblock einzunehmen.
Die Ukraine hat reagiert und hat versucht,
mit bereitgestellten Kräften selbst in die
Offensive zu gehen, jedoch wurden diese Angriffe
immer wieder abgewehrt und das Ergebnis war
schlussendlich, dass nach starken und intensiven
Kämpfen und dem Vorstoß von Wagner zentral
über den urbanen Raum schlussendlich die
ukrainische Soldaten sich absetzen mussten.
Wie schwierig die Situation für die ukrainischen
Soldaten war, das möchten wir Ihnen in diesem
Video zeigen.
[Musik]
Das Ergebnis war schlussendlich, dass am 20.
Mai 2023 die russischen Kräfte Bachmut in
Besitz genommen haben.
Jetzt muss man aber verstehen, dass es vor
allem darum geht, das center of gravity des
anderen entsprechend zu erkennen und bewerten
und auch daraus Folgerungen treffen zu können.
Wir haben schon einmal angesprochen: das center of gravity der ukrainischen Seite
ist vor allem die Unterstützung des Westens.
Der Westen wird die Ukraine nur unterstützen,
wenn er davon überzeugt ist, dass es Sinn
macht und der Erfolg der Ukraine quasi schon
mit der Hand zu greifen ist.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir das center
of gravity der russischen Seite und hier ist
es klar, dass es sich im Prinzip um die Bevölkerung
handelt und um die Frage, ob diese Bevölkerung
weiter treu zum Regime steht.
Das heißt, klar ist, dass wir versuchen müssen,
hier entsprechend auf der ukrainischen Seite
zu verhindern, dass dieses center of gravity
gefährdet ist beziehungsweise auf der anderen
Seite zu versuchen, auf das russische center
of gravity einzuwirken.
Und wie wir aus der modernen Kriegsführung
wissen, ist es so, dass Kriegsführung
über mehrere Domänen geführt wird, vor allem
auch über den Informationsraum und es geht
immer darum, diesen Informationsraum zu
dominieren. Das heißt, die Initiative muss
immer auf der einen Seite liegen und der Fall
von Bachmut ist ein gutes Beispiel, denn unmittelbar
nach dem Fall von Bachmut kam es dazu, dass
sogenannte russische Freiwillige auf russisches
Territorium vorgedrungen sind und dort Räume
in
Besitz genommen haben. Und es hat zwei
Tage gedauert für die russische Seite, diese
Kräfte zu zerschlagen.
Das Wesentliche dabei ist aber nicht der Vorstoß,
sondern der Erfolg im Informationsraum.
Denn der Sieg über Bachmut der russischen
Seite wurde somit zum Fiasko des Vorstoßes
bei Belgorod sowie auch jetzt vor kurzem noch
einmal durchgeführt an einer anderen Stelle
bei Schebekino oder das lässt uns auch denken
an die laufenden ukrainischen Angriffe mit
Drohnen in Richtung Moskau, wo es auch ganz
klar ist, dass man versucht, entsprechend hier
auf das center of gravity einzuwirken.
Trotzdem ergibt sich die Frage nach diesen
beiden von mir besprochenen Räumen im Süden
und im Zentrum, ob möglicherweise sich im
Norden eine weitere russische Angriffsführung
darstellt, beziehungsweise ob es an einer
anderen günstigen
Stelle ebenfalls zu russischen Angriffen kommt.
Und wenn wir die Front betrachten, die sogenannte
zweite Verteidigungslinie, wo sich jetzt zentral
der Raum Bachmut befindet, so sticht es ins
Auge, dass auch bei Awdijiwka sich eine ähnliche
Situation darstellt wie bei Bachmut beziehungsweise
dieser
Frontvorsprung im Raum von Siwersk, wo möglicherweise
der Versuch der Russen - so wird es zumindest
in den sozial russischen Netzwerken diskutiert -
sein könnte, hier entsprechend in einer Zangenbewegung
auch den Raum Siwersk in Besitz zu nehmen.
Etwas, das bereits letztes Jahr geplant worden
ist.
Viel wahrscheinlicher als ein russischer Vorstoß
im Raum Siwersk ist jedoch, dass in den
nächsten Wochen und Monaten es tatsächlich
zu einer ukrainischen Offensive kommt.
Die Fragen, die sich hier stellen, sind: Was
genau ist zu tun, wo genau ist anzugreifen
und welchem genauen Plan ist zu folgen?
In Expertenkreisen ist man unisono der Meinung,
dass es sich anbieten würde, die russisch
besetzten Gebiete zu teilen durch einen Vorstoß
zentral in der Mitte ostwärts von Saporischschja
in Kombination mit einem weiteren Angriff,
einem neuerlichen Angriff auf die Brücke
über die Straße von Kertsch. Damit würde
man die zwei wichtigen Bewegungslinien und
Versorgungslinien Richtung Süden entsprechend
unterbrechen und es wäre für die Russen
sehr, sehr schwierig, diese im Süden
verfügbaren Kräfte zu versorgen.
Als weiterer Vorteil würde sich ergeben,
dass aus dem Raum Don, entlang des Flusses
Don, eine sehr wichtige Handelsroute über
die Straße von Kertsch Richtung Bosporus
führt.
Das heißt: Würden es die ukrainischen Kräfte
schaffen, die Küste des Asowschen Meeres
zu erreichen, könnten sie auf diese Handelsroute
einwirken und könnten natürlich damit ein
Druckmittel gegenüber den Russen haben.
Wenn wir uns noch überlegen, was passiert
ist in den letzten Wochen, so kann man erkennen,
dass diese Angriffe vor allem begleitet werden
durch Ablenkungsmaßnahmen.
Das heißt, man wird versuchen, an mehreren
Stellen
der Front anzugreifen und man wird versuchen,
gleichzeitig auch in Russland selbst beziehungsweise
in
der Tiefe Russlands entsprechend wirksam zu
werden, um die maximale Bindung der russischen
Kräfte zu erzielen.
Wenn wir uns überlegen, dass jetzt in den Raum
zu legen, dann könnte das wie folgt aussehen:
Das erste, was wichtig ist, sind vor allem
drei Faktoren, die entscheidend sein werden.
Das erste ist Überraschung, Täuschung und
Ablenkung - das heißt, die russischen Kräfte
müssen so lange wie möglich im Unklaren
darüber
gelassen werden, wo der Hauptstoß erfolgt.
Das nächste, das wichtig ist, ist die Geschwindigkeit.
Alles, was passiert, muss sehr sehr rasch passieren,
damit die Russen völlig überwältigt sind
von den Dingen, mit denen sie konfrontiert
werden. Und das dritte Element ist eine exakte
Synchronisation der einzelnen Maßnahmen,die ergeben
ein Gesamtbild, das zum Erfolg führt.
Wenn wir uns das jetzt am Beispiel der Ostukraine
ansehen, dann könnte sich das wie folgt darstellen:
Einerseits der Umstand, dass Russland gefordert
ist, laufender Angriffe der Ukraine auf sein
Territorium entsprechend Herr zu werden.
Das bindet wieder entsprechende russische
Kräfte.
Das nächste was passieren könnte, wären
zum Beispiel amphibische Anlandungen im Süden.
Das führt natürlich neulich dazu, dass Russland
gefordert ist, hier Kräfte bereitzustellen
und diesen möglichen Anlandungen etwas entgegen
zu halten.
Dann kann es dazu kommen, dass ein plötzlicher
Vorstoß im Nordosten passiert, also zum Beispiel
im Raum Kupjansk.
Auch hier wird dann Russland gezwungen sein,
wieder neue Kräfte entsprechend in Stellung
zu bringen, um dem etwas entgegen zu halten.
Dann ein Vorstoß im Raum Saporischschja, ein
möglicher
Hauptstoß, da es sich ankündigt neuerlich
mit einer Kombination eines Angriffs auf die
Brücke über die Straße von Kertsch.
Tatsächlich ist aber auch das nur ein Ablenkungsangriff,
denn der zentrale Stoß, nachdem auch hier
die Russen Reserven eingesetzt haben, erfolgt
dann ostwärts davon im Raum Mariupol, wo man
dann versucht, von ukrainischen Seite das Schwergewicht
zu legen und rasch bis zum Asowschen Meer
durchzustoßen.
So könnte es also tatsächlich Aussehen.
Dergroße Vorteil für die Ukraine ist der sogenannte
Kampf an der inneren Linie. Das heißt, die
Ukraine kann aus dem Zentralraum relativ rasch
Kräfte
an der sogenannten inneren Linie einsetzen,
während die Russen gefordert sind, an der
sogenannten äußeren Linie von außen Kräfte
zuzuführen und das zum Teil über viele, viele
Kilometer im Eisenbahntransport. Das heißt,
die Idee ist sicherlich, auch hier so viele
Reserven wie möglich der russischen Seite
zu binden und dann den zentralen Vorstoß
entsprechend unterstützen zu können.
Nun stellt sich natürlich die Frage: Hat diese
ukrainische Offensive schon begonnen und wird
sie sich so darstellen, wie wir es gerade erklärt
haben? Dazu muss man zuerst verstehen: Wie läuft
eine militärische Offensive ab. Eine Offensive
folgt grundsätzlich drei Phasen. Die erste
Phase ist die sogenannte Vorbereitungs- oder
shaping phase, die zweite Phase ist die sogenannte
Entscheidungs- oder decision phase und die
dritte
Phase ist die Konsolidierung oder enduring
phase.
Wenn wir uns jetzt ansehen, was in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten geschehen ist, so kann man
sehr gut erkennen, dass tatsächlich von ukrainischer
Seite diese Vorbereitungsphase bereits begonnen
worden ist. Ich gebe Ihnen jetzt einige Beispiele
dafür. Das erste Beispiel habe ich schon genannt:
Das ist der Versuch der Ukraine, mit Angriffen
auf das russische Territorium oder auch mit
dem Angriff mittels Drohnen tief bis nach
Moskau
entsprechend für eine Ablenkung
zu sorgen. Das Zweite ist, dass die Ukraine
versucht, mit den vor kurzem gelieferten "Storm
Shadow"-Raketen neuerlich
tief in den russisch besetzten Gebieten Logistik-
Punkte, also Lager von Munition oder auch Treibstoffen
oder auch command and control-Punkte also Punkte
der Kommandoführung, entsprechend anzugreifen.
Das dritte Element,
das wir erkennen können, ist dass die Ukraine
versucht, entlang der Front mit kleinen Elementen
vorzustoßen, um zu erkunden, wie die russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen sich tatsächlich
darstellen. Und das letzte Element, das wichtig
ist, ist der Versuch der Ukraine, Fliegerabwehrsysteme
in Frontnähe zu stationieren, damit
sie dort geschützte Räume bilden für
den möglichen Einsatz und die Bereitstellung
von Landstreitkräften, die natürlich enger
zusammengezogen werden müssen, bevor sie unmittelbar
in den Angriff gehen. Wir wissen den letzten
Punkt deswegen so genau, weil die Russen versuchen,
durch eigene Kamikaze-Drohnen diese Fliegerabwehrsysteme
zu treffen. Und wir erkennen, dass hier
von
russischer Seite vor allem S300-Systeme angegriffen
werden aber auch vom Westen gelieferte "Avenger"-
Systeme
oder Brimstone-Systeme. Dazu zeigen wir Ihnen
ein kurzes Video.
[Musik]
Abgesehen von den Möglichkeiten der Einsatzführung
der Ukraine bei der Offensive, einer möglichen
Schwergewichtsbildung in verschiedenen Räumen
oder auch dem Umstand, wie eine derartige Offensive
aussehen kann, stellt sich natürlich die Frage,
ob in den einzelnen Domänen der Kriegsführung
die Ukraine all jene Mittel hat, um eine
derartige Offensive tatsächlich erfolgreich
durchführen zu können.
Wir sehen hier ganz
klar, dass die Ukraine in einigen Domänen
Vorteile auf ihrer Seite hat.
Einerseits ist es gelungen, neuerlich Landstreitkräfte zusammenzuführen:
Diese Brigaden der Offensive, die man für
die Offensive einsetzen kann.
Es ist auch gelungen,
eine verlässliche Kommunikation weiter aufrecht
zu erhalten, nicht zuletzt aufgrund der Verfügbarkeit
von Starlink, das sehr wichtig für die Kommunikation
der ukrainischen Truppen ist.
Es gelingt auch,
den Informationsraum zu dominieren. Das haben
uns nicht zuletzt die Ereignisse gezeigt um
Belgorod oder auch die Drohnenangriffe auf
Moskau, wo natürlich die Initiative klar
auf Seiten der Ukraine
ist.
Und es ist auch so, dass die Ukraine es schafft,
ihren Cyberraum sichern zu können, wo Angriffe
stattfinden,
die wir gar nicht am Radar haben.
Die Fragen stellen sich aber in zwei anderen Domänen:
Das ist einerseits das maritime Domain, wo
wir sehen, dass die Ukraine sehr große Schwierigkeiten
hat, etwas den Russen entgegenzusetzen. Und
vor allem die Luft. Hier sehen wir das gerade
auch an dem Einsatz der "Storm Shadow"-Raketen,
wo die Ukraine nur eine begrenzte Anzahl von
Flugzeugen hat, um diese als Träger einzusetzen
für diese Raketen beziehungsweise um diese
Waffenträger
auch zu schützen, durch möglicherweise Angriffe
durch die russische Fliegerabwehr.
Und da
ist hier ein Beispiel aus der Vergangenheit -
denken wir zum Beispiel die Landung in der
Normandie 1944, wo der Erfolg vor allem deswegen
gegeben
war, weil die alliierten Luftstreitkräfte
in den Wochen und Monaten vor der Landung
ganz gezielt die deutsche Kommunikationsstruktur
angegriffen haben beziehungsweise verhindert
haben, dass die
deutschen Panzerdivisionen, die als Reserve
in der Tiefe
eingesetzt waren, nach vorne an den Stand gekommen
sind.
Es gibt natürlich einige Gamechanger
auf beiden Seiten, die auch zu betrachten sind.
Auf der einen Seite sehen wir, dass die Ukraine
abgesehen von der Lieferung des HIMARS-Systems
durch die Lieferung von einem neuen Waffensystem,
nämlich Reichweiten-gesteigerten Bomben, in
der Lage ist, mittlerweile auf 160 km wirksam
werden zu können. Auch die Lieferung von sogenannten
JDAM-Bomben spricht in diese Richtung.
Das
Zweite ist natürlich die Lieferung dieser
"Storm Shadow"-Raketen, wo wir aufgrund der
Einsätze der letzten Wochen erkennen können,
dass es möglich ist, sehr gezielt diese Logistik-
Punkte und auch Gefechtstände anzugreifen.
Und das dritte Element sind natürlich die
bereitgestellten Brigaden der Offensive, ausgestattet
mit westlichem Gerät wie zum Beispiel hier
dieser Kampfschützenpanzer vom Typ "Bradley".
Hier ist es so, dass insgesamt 9 Brigaden mit
westlichem Gerät ausgestattet worden sind.
Zusätzlich kommen noch drei ukrainische Brigaden.
Das heißt, insgesamt 12 Brigaden, die hier
bereitgestellt werden, um als mögliche "gepanzerte
Faust" dann tatsächlich bei der offensiven
Einsatzführung entsprechend zum Einsatz zu
kommen.
Auch die russische Seite hat in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten aus ihren Erfahrungen
abgeleitet entsprechende Veränderungen
in ihrer Einsatzführung durchgeführt.
Hier
gibt es drei Elemente, die vielleicht zu berücksichtigen
sind.
Das Erste ist: Auch die Russen setzen
mittlerweile ferngelenkte Bomben ein die sie
aus einem sicheren Bereich aus dem Luftraum
heraus gegen ukrainische Bereitstellungen
einsetzen können. Das zeigen die laufenden
Videos, die hereinkommen, von Angriffen auf
ukrainische Bereitstellungsräume.
An dieser
Stelle sei auch noch einmal verwiesen auf
den mittlerweile vierten Bericht des Royal
United Service Institute, wo analysiert wird
die
russische Taktik in der Ukraine vor allem
in den letzten Monaten. Und man sehr gut erkennen
kann, dass die Ukrainer die Herausforderung
haben, dass die Russen sich zunehmend auf ihre
Einsatzführung einstellen und versuchen, ihre
Stärken wie zum Beispiel den Einsatz der
Artillerie
aber auch der elektronischen Kampfführung
auszuspielen.
Und als drittes Element ist
der Umstand zu betrachten, dass je länger
die Ukraine wartet mit dieser Offensive, desto
intensiver die russische Seite sich vorbereiten
kann durch den Ausbau möglicher Verteidigungsstellungen
entlang der gesamten Frontlinie, die mit
1.200 km natürlich sehr lange ist. Wir
sehen dass es an verschiedenen Stellen wie zum
Beispiel
bei Melitopol tief gestaffelte Verteidigungslinien
der russischen Seite gibt, bestehend aus Panzergräben,
aus Minenfeldern, aus Drachenzähnen,
aber auch Schützengräben beziehungsweise
auch aus Stellungen
für Panzerabwehrlenkwaffen oder Kampfpanzer.
An dieser Stelle möchte ich zitieren den
Leiter des ukrainischen Militärnachrichtendienstes,
der ganz klar für den Bereich der taktisch-
operativen Ebene von einer Abnutzung spricht
und den Vergleich mit einem Fußballspiel zieht.
Er sagt: Wir befinden uns in der 70. Spielminute
und es steht 1:1. Das zeigt sehr gut,
dass diese Offensive tatsächlich einen Kulminationspunkt
darstellt und entscheiden wird, wie dieser
Krieg in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
verlaufen wird.
Die Masse unserer Betrachtungen
handelte bis jetzt von der taktisch-operativen
Ebene. Wir dürfen aber die strategische Ebene
nicht vergessen und hier ist es der Fall, dass
seit dem 10. Oktober letzten Jahres die russische
Luftwaffe eine strategische Luftkampagne gegen
die Ukraine durchführt mit dem Ziel, die kritische
Infrastruktur zu zerstören. Und alleine im
Mai dieses Jahres gab es 21 Luftangriffe alleine
im Raum Kiew.
Durch die gelieferten Fliegerabwehrsysteme
des Westens ist erkennbar, dass die Abwehrfolge
der Ukraine sich steigern.
Die Ukraine selbst
gibt an, dass 93% der einfliegenden ballistischen
Raketen, Marschflugkörper und der iranischen Drohnen
abgeschossen werden können. Realistisch ist
vermutlich eine Abschussrate von ca. 80%.
Und wenn wir hier sehen, vom 2. Juni, dann
erkennen wir, dass die Ukraine weiter - auch
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten - damit
rechnen
muss, dass diese Angriffe nicht aufhören. Es
gibt Schätzungen, dass die Russen in der Lage
sind, pro Monat ca.100 Marschflugkörper zu
erzeugen. Hinzu
kommen die relativ billig gefertigten iranischen
Drohnen, die oft vor allem dazu eingesetzt
werden, die Fliegerabwehr zu sättigen, damit
diese Marschflugkörper dann ihre Ziele treffen.
Das zeigt auch, wie wichtig diese Fliegerabwehrsysteme
sind.
Die Russen versuchen auch ganz gezielt,
auf diese Jagd zu machen. Sehr gut erkennen
kann man das bei den zwei gelieferten "Patriot"-Batterien,
wo es Mitte Mai dazu gekommen ist, dass die
Russen versucht haben, in Kiew selber diese
"Patriot"-Batterie zu treffen. Und auch hier
an dieser Stelle möchten wir ein kurzes Video
zeigen, das die Ereignisse von damals zeigt,
wo Sie erkennen können, dass die eingesetzten
Werfer von dieser "Patriot"-Batterie relativ
eng beieinander platziert waren. Und dann auch
der Einschlag der russischen Rakete, der aus
ukrainischer
Sicht nicht zu signifikanten Verlusten bei
dieser "Patriot"-Batterie geführt hat.
damit bin ich bereits wieder am Ende meines
Vortrages und als letztes möchte ich wieder
den US-Generalstabschef, General Mark Milley,
zitieren,
der gesagt hat, dass die Herausforderung
für die Ukraine in Hinblick auf die Offensive
eine gewaltige ist und dass die Ukraine einige
Hindernisse zu überwinden hat, um tatsächlich
diese Offensive erfolgreich abzuschließen.
Wir wissen aus der amerikanischen Strategie,
dass die amerikanischen Streitkräfte sehr
gezielt aber portioniert an die Ukraine Waffensysteme
liefern, um zu verhindern, dass die russische
Seite in die Enge getrieben wird. Umso mehr
zeigt sich, dass gerade diese bevorstehende
Offensive - egal in welcher Form sie schlussendlich
stattfinden wird -
ein Kulminationspunkt ist, der wichtig
ist. Denn hier wird entschieden, wie dieser
Krieg tatsächlich in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten
sich darstellen wird.
Damit bin ich
am Ende meiner Ausführungen. Ich bedanke mich
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und auf Wiedersehen.